So I love the fact that you're so
open with these ideas too that you're,
you bring them to people and get their
take on it and then incorporate their
take. Is this something you've always
done because of the workshopping?
Is it just that this willingness to be
open with your ideas and express them?
Yeah, really, you know, workshop
was that the crucial thing,
having that social expectation that you're
going to bring work every week and it
was also kind of a party, a reward
for having brought the work.
And it was also a way of testing the
work so that you knew whether it was
working. You know, you weren't
constantly sort of questioning yourself.
A workshop just provides so many
really important ways of uh,
keeping, right, keeping you writing
now and you've done this always seems
like you've done this most of your career.
I have, and this is not the first
workshop I've been bumped out of.
The first workshop I was in was a very,
a lot of very nice ladies and I was
probably 28 and I had written a scene in
which, uh, a man,
a young man has done up
an inflatable sex doll.
So it looks exactly like the
woman he's obsessed with.
And during the, the
seduction of this sex doll,
he accidentally snags the back of
it with the zipper of its dress.
And he realizes during the fornication
that it is gradually losing air.
So he's got to copulate faster and faster
to try to achieve orgasm before this
thing completely goes flat.
And at the end of the scene,
he standing there with this completely
deflated sex doll hanging off of his
erection like this, the
surrender flag. And of course,
his mother walks into the room.
And after I wrote that scene,
the leader of the workshop,
I was in my first workshop,
she took me aside
afterwards and she said, uh,
the other writers in the workshop
no longer feel safe around you.
She really did. She, she said,
you've written something that
really frightens them, uh,
and they would like you
to, uh, politely, uh,
leave the workshop and not come back.
Wow. And so that's when I started with,
uh, Tom Spann Bowers workshop
in which almost anything went.
Um, and so this kind of periodic
implosion of the workshop,
uh, is, is kind of part
of the process? Well,
it seems only twice right or more
and more times than that. You know,
it's been twice, uh,
but in the past catastrophic
twice catastrophic. Yeah. Yeah.
But a few other flat
tires along the way. Uh,
periodically we've kind of had to, uh,
pretend that we were disbanding in order
to get rid of a member who was, uh,
I had just more trouble
than they were worth.
How many people were in this sport
chops? Boy, lately it's been last,
it was about eight, but we've been up
to like 16, 17. And now when I teach,
I typically have about 25 people.
What does it feel, I mean,
to be in a workshop for that
long and then have such a,
a disagreement and to disband like
that or to have you forced out,
what does that feel
like? That's gotta suck.
No, you know, I think in a way we all
need a kind of a respite from each other.
We all had kind of knew what to expect
from one another and I think we were all
less, less of a resource for
one another. Uh, you know,
there's always a chance we'll
come back together. So, uh,
so it's not a big tragedy. So
there's a chance that they might,
so did they kick you out
or did they just disband?
I left the workshop and I understood
that it disbanded wreck after that.
The seams.
I just don't understand how someone who
is a creative writer can't understand
the, the, not just the necessity,
like the need to delve into
the darker possibilities of,
of human reality that this,
the story she wrote about her grandfather
in the bird is a perfect example that,
I mean, although very few people
experience that in their life,
we all can appreciate that
these are possible scenarios.
And I think you know, it, it really
comes down to what people, uh,
what purpose reading and writing serves
in people's lives. And most people,
they want reading to be
a comforting activity.
They want to be able to read a book and
fall asleep knowing the detective will
apprehend the killer
by the end of the book.
That things will end very well in a way
they want to be bored or lulled by the
book. Uh, not so many people really
want to be kind of confronted by books,
but some people do.
Right? I mean, isn't it,
it's kind of like a pretty
much all forms of art,
whether it's music or movies. I mean,
there's superhero movies and then there's
movies like no country for old men or
the bad guy gets away at the end and
you leave the movie theater and you're
like, what the fuck? You know? But those,
those are all satisfying in
different ways to different people.
And isn't that sort of the point of
creative expression is that you're getting
surprised, you're getting
taken down a row that is,
here's the world through this person's
eyes and they create this world.
If you put limitations on
that, you're going to, yeah,
you're going to eliminate some disturbing
aspects that might bother some people,
but you're also gonna eliminate some
magical moments that might just care.
It might literally like change
the way you view people,
you know? And part of it has to do
with the nature of, you know, movies,
movies are going to always kind of
attract, uh, a more dynamic audience.
Movies carry their own
authority through motion, uh,
and books are going to be a slower
medium that's harder to consume.
And so maybe books are always
going to, at this point,
be seen as kind of a sedative as a kind
of thing that loves you and comforts you
and puts you to sleep. But by
who? By some people, right?
I mean, I mean, maybe there's a
market for those kinds of books,
but there's also a market for
your books. There's a, there's,
there's clearly a market for people
that they want to tap into those more
disturbing aspects of
consciousness and of reality.
And that market is moving to video games
and that market is moving to edgier
films.
There's just other forms of storytelling
that are serving that market better
wheelie. Oh yeah. Better than
books. Oh yeah. But why is that?
Is that because of the censorship or is
because artists aren't exploring those
ideas as much anymore? You know,
and part of it is because
books are harder to consume.
Books take an enormous amount
of a commitment of time
and effort to read a book
where everything else is 30 minutes to
two hours and to write a book as well.
It's such a solitary discipline
to sit alone with your computer.
No, it is not, not for me. And
I, I hate that model. You know,
I want to be in the mermaid Tavern
talking about my ideas with my compatriots
and getting their take on them and finding
out how it resonates with everything
else in people's lives. What's
the mermaid Tavern? Oh, is the,
the reference to where uh,
Mmm,
not Coleridge. All the famous
writers of Shakespeare's time, ah,
basically hung out at, uh, it was like
the white horse Tavern in New York,
but the mermaid Tavern was in
London during that time. Um, and uh,
Boswell, uh,
all the writers hung out
there and exchange ideas
and entertained one another.
Hmm. And so, yeah, I want
writing to be my social outlet,
but you have to write it by
yourself, right? I mean, when you're,
when you're sitting alone actually
putting your fingers on the keyboards.
No, you do it. That part
in airplanes. Really? Yeah.
I write notebooks and notebooks and
notebooks in public and then when I'm
trapped in some unbearable place,
like an airplane or an airport,
then I do that horrible
part of keyboarding. Yeah.
So that's the only time
you actually write, right?
The keyboarding is not writing. You
remember the Truman Capote quote about uh,
on the road Jack Kerouac Capote. He
said that's not writing. That's typing.
And so the,
the part on the airplane or in the
airport where you have the laptop open,
that's not writing really.
That's typing. This is writing.
Writing to you is physical pen to
paper. Ah, sloppy everything. Yeah.
Why is that? Why is it different?
Because it's written down in the moment
that you hear it and that is not set in
new times. Roman 12 points
so that it looks so finished.
It looks like a finished book and
it's much harder to monkey with it.
Once you see it on that screen and
in word, ah, it looks like a book,
it's much harder to edit it.
But when it's scrawled on the page
in front of you, you can draw arrows,
you can scribble it out, you can, you
can do whatever you want to. It is,
it's much less precious. Is
this something that you voted?
There's the approach I've always taken.
Did you learn this approach or is it
something that just sort of made sense to
you? This is how old I am. It used to be,
I grew up in the age of ah,
typewriters when even typewriters were
kind of precious because you would have
to buy ribbons for them.
And those ribbons were really expensive
and so something had to be written out
completely long hand had to be perfect
longhand before you could risk wasting a
typewriter ribbon to type it out. Wow.
So you just developed it this way and
just stuck with it even in the age of
computers? Well,
and also because writing is
something I do in the moment.
Somebody says something insightful,
something really bright,
something phrased just wrong so that it's
suddenly really fresh and I want to be
able to write it down in that moment so
that when I do have to go to the boring
part with a keyboard,
I have got so much wonderful fresh stuff
that it makes a keyboarding part fun
because it allows me to, to
sort of archive and to curate,
preserve these fantastically bright
things that were said by so many different
people. And you don't, do you ever record,
do you ever record yourself?
Like record ideas then listen to
them transcribe them? Oh God, no, no.
I hate that.
That was a big Hunter S Thompson thing
who'd record a lot of his ideas and then
transcribe them and
write them out. You know,
I kind of write word for word
sentence for sentence. And so, uh,
the transcription is just
too much of an effort for me.
Usually when I do interviews
for magazines, um,
I will record my interview
subjects. And even then, uh,
transcribing the interviews is so it's
such a misery because people seldom talk
in complete sentences and there's so
many false starts and so many sentences
that just don't go anywhere. Right. So no,
talking into a recorder
is just that a mess.
And so this notebook that you
have in front of you, this,
this is a notebook for life or this
a notebook for a particular project.
Like how do you, how do you organize it?
This is a notebook where three pages are
devoted to topics that I will talk to
you about if we're desperate.
And there are little notes in here about
contacting my for different issues.
Also, it's all universal. It's
like for all sorts of things.
It's through tasks that you need to do.
And then as well as that parts of books
you're writing and there's all these
little notes that Jamie just
gave me about microphones. Yeah.
You're writing something about someone
who's into recording equipment. Yeah.
That's just a small part of it.
But that's what she knows. Now
this, I want to go back to this
workshop thing, like what was it?
Just words, just the use of
the word faggot or the N word.
Was it just words that characters were
utilizing in your story that was so
disturbing to them?
Yeah,
it was words, but it was also some
situations that I thought were, you know,
I got that people were very upset by
people would leave the room or people
would, it would leave the
room or what would weep, uh,
would weep in just complete
upset. Does part of you go, yeah,
I got this and you see someone
weeping some shit you wrote? No.
Most of the time people would go to the
bathroom and weep and I would find out
about it much later. So, so did you
get post satisfaction that way? No.
It just made me feel like a bully and
that really kind of another thing that
it's a thin line, especially
when I read a story like guts,
am I entertaining people
or am I bullying them?
Am I beating them up? And I
also bullying why in that way?
Why do you describe it that way?
Kind of charming them into a story
that eventually will make them faint or
eventually will, will make them wretch,
but will upset them very deeply.
Uh, and I, I feel a real
reluctance about that.
Doesn't that sort of half that bridge
have to be crossed though? If you're,
if you're really going to explore
every single possibility in a creative
narrative, if you're,
if you're really gonna write a book
and just let your mind go wild,
that has to be on the table, doesn't it?
It does. But I don't think
it hurts to be aware,
uh, so that you don't lapse into being
a bully for the sake of being a bully.
You know, I think anybody who's a
really hard trainer, uh, kind of,
you know, comes up against that. Am I
a really good trainer or as part of me,
a sadist? And you have to make sure
that you don't become that sadist,
but so you're not a monster. So there
you go. Yeah. But I worry about it. Well,
that's why you're not, but it's the
being able to explore those possibilities
and being able to just delve into the
deep recesses of your mind in the
interest of creativity that seems to be of
anybody's gonna appreciate that
it's going to be creative writers,
but it's not my mind. I'm
delving into the deep recesses,
if I'm lucky, if I'm doing it right,
of your mind of something
that they'll like comedians,
they'll say, Oh my gosh,
that happened to you too.
And a lot of times they're things that
people have never ever talked about.
Uh, I tell a classic anecdote
after I had read the, uh,
the guts story at an
event, a woman came up and,
uh, and she was a middle aged woman.
She was about my age and she said,
I really love that you read
that story about how you,
uh, got your anus prolapsed while
masturbating in a swimming pool,
which is not my story, but I'm the
one that read it. So that's the one,
I'm the one that they're picturing
in this horrendous situation.
And she says, since you can tell that
story, I'm going to tell you a story.
And she said, how? When when
she was seven years old,
she was in second grade and she was
in a little organization called the
brownies, which is a
precursor to the girl Scouts.
You wear a Brown dress, little Brown
hat, you get these little merit badges.
And she said,
one day I had a stomach ache and my mom
kept me home from school and we had this
heating pad,
it must have been in the 1960s and this
heating pad had this vibrating function
and she put me face down on this heating
pad on my stomach and I fell asleep.
And while I was asleep,
this vibrating warm heating pad
must have slid down between my legs.
She says,
because I woke up with the most amazing
feeling I feeling like I had never felt
before. Oh my God, it felt so good.
And so
next time it was my turn to host
the brownies. I said, brownies,
you've got to try this heating
pad. And she says all the brownies,
they turn the heating pad on the vibrating
heating pad and they wrote it like a
pony all afternoon.
And she said it was like sex in
the city for seven year old girls.
They could not get enough of this
heating pad and they were all riding this
heating pad and they had a
great time. And she said,
and for the first time in my life I was
the most popular girl in my class and I
was the girl that all the
girls wanted to play with.
And for every brownie troop meeting it
was at my house and I was the leader
until the day that my mother came home
from work early and she caught us with a
heating pad and she sent
the other brownies home and
she whipped the cord out of
the wall.
She just ripped it out of the socket and
she started to beat me with it and she
beat me with that cord and she beat me
and she said, you fucking piece of shit.
You dirty. What kind of a
fucking whore am I raising you?
Whore. And she beat me. And
she beat me and she says,
this woman who's my age now, she says,
I have not had an orgasm
since I was seven years old.
And then she goes,
but if you can tell that swimming pool
story about how you got hurt jacking off
underwater, she says,
I can tell my heating pad story and I
can tell that story until I can make it
funny. And then maybe someday I can
go back to my mom and I can say,
do you remember that heating pad we
used to have and it will be complete.
Oh shit. As OCC CC, that's
what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to create the opening for
people to tell these stories that they,
they never thought that they could tell
because that's the way in which they're
going to resolve these stories. And
they're going to master these stories.
We have these, um,
um, but day toilet things that
have a little button on the wall,
you press it, that shoots hot
water up your ass. And, uh,
my kids come over and, uh,
they love these toilets.
I have two daughters and my
youngest, when she was seven,
she would sit on the toilet and she was
laughing and giggling and we didn't tell
her there's anything wrong with it.
So she was telling us
how much she loves it,
how much she loves the hot water when
it shoots onto her. But she was like,
it feels so good. And
there was no shame in it.
And there was this weird
moment where I'm like,
am I supposed to react to this?
Am I supposed to say? Yeah,
I know I like it too. Am
I supposed to say, Hey,
don't do that too much.
Am I supposed to say don't tell
anybody you like that you can like it,
but don't tell anybody you like it.
Like what am I supposed to do? And uh,
I didn't do anything.
I just let her smile and she walked out
of the bathroom laughing like it was
great and it was, no, there was no issue.
But it was this moment
where I was like, wow,
if I was a religious person
or a suppressive person
or some person with some
sexual issues, this could be a
real problem for this little girl.
Instead I was like, okay, let's
get out of the bathroom now.
I guess you're done. Alrighty.
And she has no idea that this
was even like a moment of,
you know, crisis in my mind or I was
like, okay, how do I handle this?
I'm in the bathroom with
my seven year old daughter,
just can't water shot up her
ass and she's enjoying it.
What do you talk about it on the
radio? Is that how you deal with it?
I enjoy it to share. I enjoy it too.
We all do. We talk about these toilets.
They're amazing. It's warm water
shoots in your, it's great. Feels awesome,
but it's not supposed to feel awesome
for like a little girl for some reason.
Right. Is he?
You tell that story and people will have
so many versions of that story. Yeah.
For me, I was in Germany. I went
in the bathroom in the airport.
I didn't know what this
button was. So I pressed it.
I looked down just in time to see
this little plastic arms swing out.
I didn't know what that
thing was going to do.
So I jumped off the head and this
thing shot up with such force.
It knocked a ceiling panel out of the
ceiling and all this hot toilet water came
sprinkling down on me. Uh, and I,
that's the only time I've ever been around
one of those. Well, we have one here.
If you want to try it out, I don't
know. Scares me. There's two of them.
There's one in that
bathroom, one in that one,
one of that one bathroom you
could lock. It's private. And see,
that's my process is you can tell these
stories and you kind of gathered the
stories that people tell
related to these stories.
And you choose the ones that escalate
the fastest, the escalate the best.
And that gives you a gradual sort of,
you've established the precedent
and then something worse.
Escalating Wars escalating, worse,
escalating to the most
atrocious or extreme version.
And that's what brings a story to crisis.